[Music]
you see this on the web I don't he saw
this on the web there's a college
student who holds up a large cutout of
his own head making a funny face at
basketball games to cause a distraction
to other teams take a look this is a
photograph this is still well I mention
us for a reason I mention it because we
have someone doing the same thing in our
audience tonight and it's freaking me
out
[Applause]
it's very distracting yeah okay sir
would you just would you please stop
would you just stop it okay just stop
what you're doing no yeah I mean what do
you mean what do you mean who me yes I'm
talking to you yes you look I'm sorry
I've got a show to do here okay I have a
show to do and I can't waste time
talking to someone in that that's making
it worse
now don't apply for him don't encourage
him
sir I'm sorry but you know what you're
gonna have to leave you're just gonna
have to go I'm gonna have security
escort you out be good
he can stay
hello
don't don't do that to it no no no we
got a stupid show tonight
what else is changed yeah tonight